[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and Speaker of amazing facts
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live would you like to hear an
amazing fact in order to demonstrate how
important it is to think ahead Amazon
founder and billionaire Jeff Bezos
is dedicating 42 million dollars to
build a single clock but this is not
just any clock the 10,000 year clock is
designed to measure time on a millennial
scale the Clarkes creator computer
scientist Danny Hillis has a vision for
a timepiece that ticks once every year
with a century hand that moves just once
every hundred years and a cuckoo that
emerges every 1,000 years the clock is
now under construction on property owned
by BSO's in a very remote rock mountain
in the middle of a Texas desert the 500
foot deep tunnel that will house the
mechanism has already been drilled and
assemblies now in progress according to
the long now foundation that oversees
the project the clock is designed to
capture energy from changes in
temperature to power the apparatus the
clocks chime generator will create a
different bell-ringing sequence for each
day for 10,000 years carved into the
mountain beside the clock apparatus are
going to be five rooms that are sized
for different anniversary chambers one
for the one-year anniversary the 10-year
hundred year thousand year and yes at
ten thousand year anniversary room in
the first room the clock will activate
and run a planetarium model once a year
v Zoe's in the designer are going to let
other centuries and generations figure
out what to do with the other years
according to the 10,000 year clock
website visitors will be welcome to view
the
massive timepiece but be prepared for a
rough trip the nearest airport is
several hours away by car and you need
to scale a rugged 2,000 foot trail to
reach the clock did you know the Bible
says that God is going to give the devil
a one thousand year timeout after Jesus
comes stay with his friends were going
to learn more on this edition of Bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 do have some
lines open but call now to get your
question on tonight's program
800 four six three seven two nine seven
and my name is Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross get even listening friends
real sort of welcome those who are
joining us on Facebook across the
country and if you do have a Bible
question we want to encourage you to
give us a call that number again is 800
four six three seven two nine seven
that'll bring you here to the studio
with your Bible question pastor Doug
let's start the program with a word of
Prayer dear father in heaven we thank
you on once again that we're able to
take some time to open up your word and
study this evening we want to ask your
blessing be with those listening and
guide us here as we open search the
scriptures in Jesus name Amen
well someone investing a lot of money
what did you say 40-plus a million
dollars to create a clock that's
supposed to last at least 10,000 years
yeah 42 million yeah what's that four or
five million right yeah it's pretty
incredible
and yeah they got a website anyone can
go look at Jeff Bezos was tweeting about
it it's kind of a project he's very
interested in and when you I guess
technically he is the richest man in the
world now he's got what 50 billion
dollars I'm not sure how much and so you
know I want to make something that is
going to be around for a thousand years
that kind of appeal
some people and so they're making this
massive clock with very carefully
machined solid components that
supposedly you won't be have to oil or
maintain that it's just gonna go on its
own without any human interference
taking away once a year for ten thousand
years now that was that would be if the
Lord didn't come but you know I highly
suspect Jesus is coming in the near
future and many Christian theologians
believe in what they call the seven
thousand year in theory Martin Luther
believed this and Jane Andrews a number
of others the idea that you look at the
date of creation approximately four
thousand years bc there were no one
knows exactly and you've got you know
two thousand years from Adam to Abraham
two thousand years from Abraham to Jesus
right now we're living about two
thousand years from Jesus time to the
present that's six thousand years and
then Revelation says we get like a
thousand years Sabbath where we live and
reign with Christ and you can read about
that thousand years sometimes known as
the millennium now the word millennium
is not in the Bible just like you don't
find the word Bible in the Bible and you
don't find the word Trinity in the Bible
but the teaching is there millennium
simply means milli thousand annum years
revelation 20:4 one it says I saw an
angel come down from heaven having the
key to the bottomless pit and a great
chain in his hand and he laid hold of
the dragon the serpent of old was a
devil and Satan if you had any question
about who the devil is it says it's
Satan it's the dragon it's the servant
and bound him a thousand years and cast
him into the bottomless pit and shut him
up and set a seal on him that he should
deceive the nation's No More till the
thousand years were finished but after
this he must be loosed for a little
season so the devil is gonna get bound
we're gonna get wrest from the devil you
might say for a thousand years he's
getting the time out people wonder to
know what is the bottomless pit and
where is the bottomless pit and why
would God let him out of the bottomless
pit after a thousand years
you've got questions on the subject of
the millennium or that 1000 years then
we've got a free offer that talks all
about it this free offer is part of our
amazing fact study guide series and it's
called a thousand years of peace it's
all about this Revelation chapter 20
this 1000 year time period and this is
the free offer for anybody who'd like to
learn more about that the number to call
is eight hundred eight thirty five six
seven four seven that is our resource
phone line and you can answer the study
guide called a thousand years of peace
and why are you they are on the phone
you might as well sign up it's free for
our amazing fact study guide series it's
just a fantastic course that'll take you
through twenty seven lessons dealing
with some very important Bible truths
what we're ready to go to the phone
lines our first call this evening is
tightly listening in Oklahoma I believe
Tyler welcome to the program hi I'm
Tyler and I'm from Oklahoma City and I'm
11 how are you dog I'm doing good
Thank You Tyler for calling in what's
your question tonight my question is in
Deuteronomy thirty four or five it put
on first Moses read Deuteronomy right
yeah so how could Moses write about his
own day if he died oh yeah good question
well you find that also in the book of
Joshua and even in the book of Samuel
the book is named after them but it
doesn't mean they wrote every chapter
because obviously the the epitaph in the
end of the book Moses couldn't write
about his death and tell how wonderful
he was because he was dead so you know
probably Joshua who was the six-seater
of Moses he wrote that and then in the
book of Joshua after Joshua dies it
talks about Joshua as some believe that
Ezra who is a spirit-filled scribe he
went and compiled many of the Old
Testament books after the Babylonian
captivity and under the inspiration of
the Spirit he wrote a couple of the post
scripts on some of these books and and
so some have wondered who that was but
probably
Joshua wrote the end of Deuteronomy
where it talks about the death of Moses
good question you know we do have a book
that you might find interesting
Tyler that talks about the Bible maybe
not specifically this question but the
Bible in general how do we get the Bible
it's called the ultimate resource we're
happy to send that book to you it's a
book that pastor Doug wrote to receive
it for free just call 883 five six seven
four seven you're gonna answer the book
the ultimate resource or you can just go
to the amazing facts or website you can
read it for free online that's just
amazing facts dot o-r-g or.com annex
water that we have is ginger listening
from looks like Nebraska ginger welcome
to the program hello hi thank you for
calling thank you my question is let's
you recognize your relatives when you go
to heaven does that just mean your
adoptive parents or your biological
parents since I was adopted when I was a
baby I don't know if that means that I
might recognize my biological parents or
just my adoptive parents well you know
when you get to heaven you're you'll not
only have your mental senses of
discernment but we will have
supernatural discernment because we'll
all be spirit filled and God's Spirit
will be guiding us and of course you'll
be thrilled if your biological parents
are in heaven that's our first hope you
know we we're we'd love to believe that
all of our loved ones will be there and
if they are there I'm sure the Angels
will show you the record book and say
hey take a look and you know the Bible
you read in I think it's first
Corinthians 13 it says then I will know
even as I am known speaking of heaven
pastor Ross had a thought yeah I was
just gonna end you mention that pastor
Doug the angels of course they know who
our parents are they know our relatives
our that we perhaps they've never even
met and if the in heaven I think the
Angels will be delighted to introduce us
to family members that we might not have
known here on this earth so kind of neat
great reunion day when Jesus come and
amen well thank you good question and
you know we do have some study guides
that talk about the resurrect
in the second coming of Jesus where it
talks about the ultimate deliverance yes
we'll be happy to send it to anybody who
calls and asks that's again part of our
study guide series I just call 883 five
six seven four seven you're gonna ask
the study guide called the ultimate
deliverance we'll be able to send that
to anybody who calls and asks our next
call is Gavino listening from Texas I
believe it's Covino welcome to the
program yes good evening pastors evening
love Brisebois testimony I will look
drunk for twenty years I started going
to church pastor asked me to join I said
well I feel a little hypocrite and I
still drink every day I cannot get out
without a drink my way so yes II do I
want to stop right there yes and after
they pray for me as soon as they finish
praying the crazing just walk away
instantly that's that's a miracle yes it
is the issue I have I see that I have
other sense that that are magnified and
I cannot control them so therefore I
doubt myself Alicia and sometimes I just
want to give up well you know first of
all it's the grace of God that gave you
victory over alcohol and I think that
and I know exactly what you're talking
about the Lord miraculously saved me
from a number of things when I came to
him but I noticed he didn't take
everything away because he wanted me to
course to recognize my dependence on him
and so some things you need to wrestle
through even Paul said you know we
wrestle not against flesh and blood and
Paul said we need to fight the fight of
faith
and we need to run the race and we need
to wage the war and so terms of great
effort are connected with the Christian
life people who say that you know once
you accept Jesus that all temptation is
gone that's not what the Bible says
there's all kinds of body
the Bible has language that talks about
all kinds of striving that goes on you
know I'm reminded of the story that we
have in the class
of how that the disciples will st. out
by Christ and they were performing
miracles they were casting out all kinds
of devils and on one occasion they
weren't able to cast this devil out and
it puzzled them and finally Jesus came
and Jesus cast out the devil and said
well why couldn't we throw cast out that
devil Jesus said this kind comes out
with praying fasting and I think in in
our lives there are certain aspects or
certain struggles that we might have or
temptations that require a little more
prayer and maybe even some fasting and
only being the victory and God does not
deliver us of every sin the same way
sometimes you really go to plead for
that deliverance our faith has to be
tested yeah sometimes it's not the same
way and sometimes not all the same day
either right sometimes we grow so don't
become discouraged and you know I'm
trying to think we've got a number of
books that a pastor Cruz wrote about the
Christian life and there's a book called
the power of a positive know that talks
about victory against temptation would
you like us to send you a free copy of
that yes the power of a positive no I
think it'll encourage you you know the
number to call is let me give you that a
quick response sure there's a quick
response
I believe he created that miracle
because I was only throwing blood up
when I was on my on my deathbed so I
think he needed to do that but I I just
understand that there are sins that I
still enjoy yes if you just give me that
number sure the number to call is 883
five six seven four seven you can ask
for the book called power or the
positive you know it's a good book a
power of a positive no 883 five six
seven four seven and of course all of us
have to claim the promise where the
Bible says no temptation is falling you
which is not common to man but God will
provide a way of escape that's right so
you must never give up you know and we
might mention together you know that if
he wants to read that right now he can
go to the amazing facts website right
and I think that book is one that you
can download for free next quarter that
we have is Mark listening in Florida
mark welcome to the program thanks hey
my question has to do it
course of endtime events I want to know
which comes first seven last plagues or
the close of probation the close of
probation happens I believe before the
seven last plagues and once the plagues
fall
no one is converted from the plagues
because it tells us that they're cursing
the Lord isn't your understanding yeah
absolutely you looking at Daniel chapter
12 it says Michael shall stand up
meaning that probation closes and then
it says there's a time of trouble worse
than the world has ever seen
and of course there's other passage in
Revelation that indicate now of course
some people asked well why would Christ
or why would God allow the place to fall
after probation is closed and people
can't change sides well the purpose of
the plagues there is a judgment
component but it's also revealing what
is actually in the heart after the place
for the righteous
trust in God they know their deliverance
has come but the wicked instead of their
hearts been softened they turning
rebadging against God and they curse God
blaspheme it says yeah and when it when
it says Michael stands up it's like at
the end of a court when a judge stands
up they're not listening to evidence any
more cases are closed so yeah that's a
good verse I hope that helps a little
bit and by the way we do have a book if
you'd like a free copy on who is Michael
the Archangel we'll send that to you if
you'd like that mark yes the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you can ask to the
book called who is Michael the Archangel
and we also have a study guide called
case closed
which I believe talks about the judgment
and the close of probation I'll be happy
to send both of those to you Marco
anybody who calls and asks the number is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and I'm Nicola that we have
let's see we've got Josie listening from
Georgia
Josie welcome to the program hi how are
you doing well thank you for calling I'm
so excited
yeah well take a stab at it okay it's
actually for my son he he asked me he
said God knows everything so he knows
that we're going to go to hell or if
we're going to go to heaven
so what is the point of trying if it's
already you know you've already
predestined well god yeah God knowing
doesn't mean we don't have freedom tell
your son that it's something like the
weatherman has a satellite up in the sky
and he can see when a car is getting
ready to drive over a cliff but he's not
making the car drive over the cliff he
just has an advanced view and so God
knowing all things he knows the future
but it doesn't mean he's taken away our
freedom to make choices so you know we
would all like to know ahead of time am
I gonna make it and if we know we're
gonna make it I guess we try harder and
if we don't know that we're gonna make
it we might throw our hands in the air
but that's where Jesus said have faith
you're gonna make it and you will and
like the the spies that went to the
promised land those who did not believe
they could conquer the Giants they did
it
those who believed they could they did
and you know the Jets will live by faith
so tell your son believe you're gonna
make it and live like you're gonna make
it and you'll make it okay so if say if
somebody was being bad and going towards
the bad path could they have a change of
heart
sure that's that's the story of the
Bible you've got I can name a lot of
people I'm one of them
you got the prodigal son who ended up in
a pig pen but he had a change of heart
and he came home you've got King
Manasseh who was a wicked King
worshiping foreign gods but he repented
and he was forgiven and the Bible's full
of stories of God's incredible grace now
what is it Ezekiel 18 where he says if
the wicked man turns from his wickedness
all his wickedness will be forgotten
right you know it's important for us to
remember that when we pray and we ask
God for help God deals with us with
where we are at the moment
sometimes we attempted to think well
what's the point of him praying because
you know maybe I'm lost and so God's not
going to answer my prayer no if we pray
in sincerity God will answer our prayer
irrespective of what our final destiny
is it doesn't make a decision based on
what will happen some distant future he
makes a decision to help us right now
because we're calling upon him mm-hmm
thank you so much thank you
and thank you for your call and I'm just
trying to think we've got a book that
you would enjoy it's called three steps
to heaven and we'll send your FREE copy
the number to call is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
you can answer the book called three
steps to heaven I'll be happy to send it
to anyone who calls and asks next caller
that we have is Danny and he's listening
from Washington Danny you're on Bible
answers live hi I'm glad to hear you're
all doing well I have a question for you
about the third temple is there gonna be
a third temple built what you can gain
from the Bible that'd be a temporary
peace between the Palestinians and
Israelis allowing it long enough to
build the third temple apparently they
have all the adornments you do and you
know I heard an interesting I got an
email from someone people send me all
kinds of interesting facts and I guess
the there's a third temple group kind of
a some advocates in Israel that want to
build the third temple and they just
minted a shekel coin with Trump's face
on it I think they got Cyrus on one side
and Trump on the other because he's
moving the capital to Jerusalem so
they're meant a national with some space
on it and they but let me tell you I
don't believe I think the Third Temple
is under construction now but it's not
what you think pastor Ross war is at
second Thessalonians where he says he'll
sit in the temple of God you want to
find that for me real quick and some
people read this verse in 2nd
Thessalonians and they think it means
that they're gonna build a third Jewish
temple but Christ said destroy this
temple made with hands and in three days
I'll raise it up he spoke of his body
the church is called the body of Christ
and Peter said we are living stones and
Jesus is the cornerstone and Paul says
in Ephesians that we are being built up
to a spiritual house and Paul said don't
you know that you are the temple of God
and so the temple in the world today
we're sacrifices are offered are the
people of God it's not a physical
edifice
so personally I think all the hubbub
about rebuilding the temple I'm
half-jewish and most of the the Jews
don't practice sacrifice anymore that's
been abandoned for nineteen hundred
years and that was the main thing they
did in the sanctuary
yeah the verse is made about a second
Thessalonians chapter 2 verse 4 talking
about this Antichrist power says who
opposes and exalts himself above all
that is called God that which is
worshiped so that he sits as God in the
temple of God showing himself that He is
God now I think what he just read is
talking about the beast power putting
himself over the spiritual temple of God
the church claiming to be God I don't
think it's a beast power in throning
himself in a Jewish temple because the
Jews had no throne for a human in their
temples you know one more additional
phone on that it's very significant when
Jesus began his public ministry and he
cleansed the temple he said make not my
father's house a house of merchandise
it's a house of prayer but right at the
end just the very last time in Jesus
left the temple he said to the religious
leaders your house is left to you
desolate it's as if the temple is
disowned by God by Christ at that point
so if a temple is rebuilt in Jerusalem
it's not going to have any spiritual
significance as relates to the church or
God's spiritual Israel because now focus
is on heaven where the heavenly temple
is and Jesus is ministering for us yeah
that's why he told the disciples when
they showed him all the beautiful stones
in the temple he said don't you see all
these things there won't be one stone
left upon another that won't be thrown
down and when Christ died the veil in
the temple was torn signifying the whole
purpose for the earthly temple was
fulfilled we don't need to sacrifice
lambs now it's the Lamb of God so there
has been discussion for two thousand
years that maybe some day they would get
their land back and rebuild a temple but
in my opinion the Jews would never
settle for building a temple anywhere
other than the Temple Mount and right
now there is the third most holy Muslim
a shrine on that piece of real estate it
would cause World War 3 if the Jews went
up there with d9s and
started to demolish the mosque of Omar I
really don't think that's gonna happen
hey that's a great question and we have
a book that talks about spiritual Israel
and it talks about the temple in there
if you call an S we'll send you a free
copy of spiritual Israel the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you can ask for the
book called spiritual Israel pastor Dai
interest thought you did a sermon series
not too long ago it was something a
little different about Islam in Bible
prophecy and I think you addressed a
little bit relating to Jerusalem and
some of the conflict over the temple and
the things connected with that I think
that video is for free online yeah it's
actually a series that three videos
Christianity Islam and prophecy and I
understand been very popular if you just
type that into Google or YouTube it
seems like everything's up there right
people would buy the DVDs but about a
month later then they just post it on
YouTube and own buys them anymore next
one that we have is Michael listening
from Michigan Michael welcome to the
program guys I don't know how long turns
into a Bible question really the
question I'm gonna do the best I can see
what happens a shot um is it how okay is
it okay to listen to like non-christian
music I don't know how that's a good
question yeah you know you you phrased
it pretty well now Michael let me just
give you a heads up we may get
interrupted before I finish answering
your question with our bottom of the
hour break if we do we'll come back and
finish with you so if you hear music in
the background
we're not dumping you just hang on but
is it okay for a Christian to listen to
non-christian music you know the Bible
says whatever things are good and holy
and Noble just true think on these
things and it is possible that you know
Christians couldn't participate in folk
music as long as it doesn't violate a
Christian principle there's some you
know if you sing god bless america
that's the patriotic song it doesn't
mean the Christian can't sing that
because it's not technically a religious
song
there might be a romantic song you would
sing to your girlfriend or your wife
hopefully if you have a wife you don't
also have a girlfriend unless she is
your wife but you've got the Song of
Solomon in the Bible which is a romantic
song and so there's a right place for
those things but there's so another
principles about music you want to be
sensitive to so much music these days is
sexually suggestive so it stand by Mike
and will maybe pick you up after the
break if you don't mind holy and on
friends we are gonna have this a brief
break in a few moments don't go anywhere
more Bible questions coming your way and
some important announcements
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return in a moment
[Music]
life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control
wham you're hit with something new your
marriage is good
suddenly it's on the brink of divorce
that job's great and then it's gone and
so's your life savings you feel healthy
Daniel doctor gives the bad news what's
coming next
you could look to the stars but they
don't have the answers but this does the
prophecy Study Bible by amazing facts
this Bible special its 27 personal study
guides leave you on a life-changing
journey from God's Word to discover real
answers to life's questions from health
and relationships to family and the
future the hopes in here get your
amazing facts prophecy study bible today
by calling
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 that he that
endures to the end will get through so
don't give up our operators are taking
the calls and we line people up 1 also
welcome our friends that are watching on
Facebook and we know some of you are
watching because we can tell from the
calls we want to greet you and that's
just on the Doug Batchelor public
Facebook site he'll be able to look and
see whatever it is you'll see us here in
the studio we're not dressed in our
tuxedos but this is how it looks when we
do the radio program and hey thank you
all so the I of course they're you know
the best thing is that you wears it in
Ephesians Paul says speaking to
yourselves in Psalms and hymns and
spiritual songs you know we can
encourage ourselves God's got a hymnal
in the Bible it's called The Book of
Psalms and you know David wrote about 70
of them there's a hundred and fifty
Psalms so there's a lot of
beautiful music in the Christian
traditions that supports Scripture now
there are some things that people call
Christian music and and they'll just say
one or two words over and over again and
it's it's almost like Eastern meditation
and sometimes they put it to hypnotic
music and I almost feel like that's anti
Christian or anti productive music for a
Christian and so just because someone
calls something Christian music doesn't
always mean it is Christian music you
know there is some some good music out
there that might not be specifically
Christian but um it's good music I you
like sittin mic on you but I have these
preset radio stations and I have two
classical musical stations I like that
you know you've got some great thinking
music yeah I mean those are things that
I think are good here's the verse you're
referring to pastor Doug Ephesians
chapter 5 verse 19 saying speaking to
one another in Psalms and hymns and
spiritual songs singing and making
melody in your heart to the Lord amen
now Mike I have a series you can listen
to for free online if you just go to the
amazing effects website or YouTube Doug
Batchelor the music and the Christian is
what I think it's titled music and the
Christian I think it's a two-part series
and I go through the principles of music
that's what you want as principals you
don't want a preacher saying this is a
good song that's a bad song cuz you've
got to be able to think for yourself
Anika that we have a is shown listening
from Illinois Sean welcome to the
program do we have Sean from Illinois
Meudon sometimes they don't realize it
Sean going once
Sean was waiting patiently going twice
alright we might come back coming from
Illinois one more time all right all
right we'll come back we've got URI
listening from Missouri Gary welcome to
the program hey can you hear me yes yeah
hey pastor Ron and pastor dog kind of
cool because you guys already talked in
the beginning a little bit about Satan
and the devil being the same creature
the question is pretty simple how do we
really can prove from that from the
Bible that Satan and Lucifer are the
same person
well that actually is more difficult the
oh there's only one place that you find
the word Lucifer if I'm not mistaken
pastor Ross and that's isaiah 14 and
it's i think the word Lucifer is coming
from a word Morningstar or morning light
it's making it pretty clear that here is
this fallen angel just read the context
how you were fallen from heaven o
Lucifer son of the morning and I think
it starts with verse 12
yeah well verse 12 how you fallen from
heaven o Lucifer son of the morning how
you are cut down to the ground and
here's a key you who weakened the
nation's of course you know the devil is
referred to by Christ as the Prince of
this world and then it talks about how
you said in your heart I will ascend
into heaven I'll exalt myself above the
stars of God I'll be like the Most High
and so on so you look at the
characteristics given it's the
characteristics of Satan characteristics
of the devil yeah so and I think the
word for Lucifer comes from the Hebrew
word Kali now yeah it means morning star
the actual word is highly L and it means
a star in the sense of its brightness
you know he was a bright angel you can
read about that also in Ezekiel as at 28
talks about covered every precious stone
a beautiful angel so that's the only way
you can prove the Lucifer is the devil
as you just read the context of chapter
14 now we do have a study guy that goes
into more detail has all the scriptures
on this subject now if people want to
know about understanding the enemy so
they can resist his temptations then get
our study guide did God create a devil
the number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask the study guide
called did God create a devil I'll be
happy to send it to anybody who calls
and asks and again friends I want to
remind you you can sign up for free for
the amazing facts online correspondence
school we can even do it online or you
can actually do it the old-fashioned way
through the mail but you'll learn so
much as we go through those lessons and
it's holy that we have is looks like we
could gary listening an illinois gary
welcome to the program hello hello
podcasters hi thank you for calling hi
dog I just wanted to tell you real fast
that uh two years ago I ran across one
of your videos on YouTube it caught my
attention I watched it all the way
through and right towards the end of the
video I broke down in tears I could feel
the hair standing up on my neck your
sermon literally woke up the spiritual
miss in me and I have been for two years
now following God every single day
there's not a day that goes by I don't
think a lot of my eyes I listen to you
so you thanks to you you brought me to
God and he is well in my life right now
that's another thing
one other thing is funny is I called 20
times and got a busy signal before I was
able to get through after the 20th time
I got on my knees I took a break from
calling calling calling back I took a
break for a minute and I prayed to God I
said if it's your will Lord I'd really
like to talk to this pastor I just find
that amazing that I can talk to him now
and if it's your will and you know what
I got I'm praying saying amen I called
and the phone was ringing well I believe
it was and he answered my prayer
instantly well now I'm really excited to
hear the question after all that okay
now here's my question I've got my King
James Version Study Bible open right now
it's brand new I paid $80 for it at
Barnes and Noble and the big I've been
doing the research now for two years
researching and reading and praying
going to church and stuff faithfully on
the Sabbath day and all that good stuff
well there's 75 different verses in the
Bible that described the creation of the
earth and even in Genesis the second day
God said let there be a firmament in the
midst of the waters and let it divide
the waters from the waters
and God made the firmament and divided
the waters which were under the
firmament and the waters which were
above the firmament so I watch a lot of
your sermons
I noticed and a lot of the backgrounds
you have a round globe and I just wanted
to ask
to what your thoughts are on a flat
earth because everything that I'm
finding describes the earth is round
from a bird's eye view with ice walls
surrounding the oceans and there is
actually a crystallite dome overhead
called the firmament and outside the
dome is water there are space and NASA
and all that stuff they're saying is
alive there's no water space all right
leave her yeah let me let me jump in
here and just share with you what and
I've heard this I you know when I
probably very honest with you when I
first heard somebody share this I was
surprised because I grew up a pilot my
dad was a pilot in World War two my sons
were pilots and I've flown all over the
world
pastor Ross and I leave for India this
next weekend yeah we yeah at about a
weekend and it is just about the other
side of the planet from where we are in
California I can guarantee you that the
world is round I know I've heard some
very interesting theories that the world
is actually flat where it tells us that
there's a firmament that separates the
waters below from the waters above
that's of course describing the world
before the flood when it never rained
the environment was very different
there was probably a polarizing even
cloud of waters or something or around
the world before the flood they could
see through it and see the Sun Moon and
stars we know from the planet and the
fossils that there were very there were
very tropical regions in Siberia they
were there were ferns growing up there
and and a lot of oil that is now there
because of all the vegetation so the
world has gone through a radical change
from what you see described there in
Genesis but the Bible says that God you
know hangs the earth on nothing it talks
about the circle of the earth and yeah I
I don't believe that this is a big plot
from Hollywood I don't know what the
point of it would be to try and prove
that there really is space matter of
fact one of the astronauts was a friend
of our church and he really did go to
the moon he
he didn't walk on the moon but he was in
the lunar orbiter
so yeah I just would have to
respectfully disagree with the Flat
Earth theory yeah you know if you look
at the world was quite as past that I've
mentioned the world was quite different
before the flood when the Bible speaks
of the windows of heaven being opened
some feel that prior to that there was a
layer of water probably ice like a
shield surrounding the earth kept the
earth somewhat tropic a lot more trouble
than it is now and when the flood came
where did all the water come from
well large portion of that came from
this canopy that surrounded the earth
and there is some very good scientific
explanations for a lot of the things
that we see in the world today and the
solution for that being the flood so
yeah I don't think that is it Ellen Musk
and SpaceX just staged this whole thing
where they sent the largest rocket there
were so many witnesses there into space
and he had GoPro cameras that are still
streaming it right now I think it's real
anyway but I appreciate your question
and praise the Lord for your conversion
brother and though we probably ought to
get another caller
all right next quota that we have is
looks like Jonathan he's calling from
Canada Jonathan welcome to the program
hi hi thanks for calling it's nice to be
speaking with you pastor Doug and your
question um well I just got reconnected
with my father my birth father probably
less than a year ago after he walked in
many years ago and okay so small bit of
background before I get to the question
I was raised in a baptist family and I
grew up pretty much my childhood and my
teen years going to Baptist churches and
but over I got I guess you could say the
more cynical I got to a lot of the
teachings and I back slit and then when
I came back to those face it was more of
a radical experience of God revealing
create
to me in a new way and so I started to
study the Bible more and a friend of
mine who was a seventh-day adventists
she started talking to me about the
Sabbath and I looked into it further and
I end up getting baptized in the
seventh-day Adventist Church
but this reconnection with my father has
brought more heat than before and it's
it's known under-eye grudge you know you
know him being angry and me being angry
it's now a cause a battle of what the
true Sabbath is now I know based on
Scripture and I've watched many of your
programs if not all I'm dealing with the
Sabbath and I write down the verses if
not I try to memorize them I'm not
really good at remembering locations but
there's just a couple that kind of stuck
out to me now I usually argue with the
Bible and sometimes she'll argue with
the Bible but very rarely it mostly
seems like and an opinionated side from
tradition of you know a Baptist
upbringing and the tumors that really
caught my attention was Galatians 3
8-hour it says and the scripture
foreseeing that God would justify the
heathen through faith preached before
the gospel unto Abraham saying in thee
shall all nations be blessed and then
you go over to mark 27 or 227 and I
believe it's Jesus speaking and he said
unto them the Sabbath was made for man
and not man for the Sabbath now he
didn't jump in with the next verse which
kind we get it we're gonna run out of
time brother we need to turn it into a
question I can answer
I know I kind of hear where you're going
but we need to summarize this so my
question is it gets to a heated argument
and I know there's a lot of verses out
there that get misunderstood and used to
justify Sunday one of the more loving
way I can introduce the Sabbath to him
slowly but gradually without it becoming
a heated debate well from what you're
telling me I think that you ought to
right now drop the subject I know he
might think that's a strange thing but
if you guys are getting hot and arguing
about it then the whole spirit of the
subject is lost because the Lord wants
us first of all to you know just do
everything in love
if you can't force someone to believe
something if you and your father are
having a disagreement and it gets hot
and you're finding yourself arguing
about your respective positions I think
the best thing to do is just live out
your faith show your peace do not feel
that you are compelled to convince your
father and and when he's open there's
only three things you can do to share
truth with people one is be a good
witness the other is if they're open you
share information and the third thing is
you pray right now from what you're
saying I think you ought to do point two
and three pray and be a good witness
doesn't seem like when you share
information seems like he's entrenched
in his belief you obviously are firm
about your beliefs the verse in
Galatians I don't really see is a
problem with you know just what you said
the Sabbath was made for man Christ is
referring back to the Garden of Eden
that word there's for man is talking
about humanity mankind not one race of
people so that I think is further
endorsement but you've probably seen all
the information that we have on the
subject I think one of the best things
is we got a website
yeah it's called Sabbath truth calm and
it's got a lot more information so video
also some Bible studies there I think
you'll find that helpful anyone wanting
to learn more about what the Bible has
to say about the Sabbath the next one
that we have is let's see we have Mario
listening in Canada Mario often of the
program hello good evening pastor Doug
good evening thank you for calling Mario
I have my question then I would have a
follow-up question bastard if you would
wouldn't mind well let's hear the first
question the first question is is
believing in Jesus a requirement for
salvation well I'll tell you the Bible
tells us in the book of Acts there is no
other name given among men whereby we
must be saved so there may be some
people in the Old Testament times and
others that did not know about Jesus
that lived up to the light that God gave
them but if a person is you know
presented Christ they're not gonna be
saved by Budda Budda is not a savior and
they're not gonna be saved by Mohammed
so what is your follow-up question I'm
just wondering where you're heading with
this so my follow-up question is this
there could be some there could be a
possibility that there could be some
people who have never heard anything
about Jesus what would happen to them
when Jesus comes back okay I see what
you're saying that that's it that is a
just a reasonable question let me just
put it this way I've been to Australia
and I went out to the out outback way
out where the the Aborigines are still
living and there were thousands of years
where there were no missionaries talking
to them about Jesus or you can have
people in North America South America
Africa who just millenia went by they
never really heard a missionary come
does that mean all those multiplied
millions of people that never had an
opportunity to hear about Christ are
they all automatically lost attend no
because you there are gonna be some
people who are saved because they lived
up to the light that God gave them
either through the Holy Spirit or
through angels most people not hearing
about Jesus won't know and it's that's
why we do send missionaries is because
most people will be lost without a
knowledge of the gospel you can read in
Romans chapter 1 I think pastor Ross
where he says that God speaks to even
the heathen there's a law written in
their hearts
that if they follow the law that God has
given them in their hearts and in their
conscience they may find grace from God
to believe and be saved by faith that's
Romans chapter 2 verse 15 yeah so you
know and then Christ said many will come
from the east and the west and sit down
in the kingdom with Abraham Isaac and
Jacob Jesus talked about a Gentile woman
that believed through the influence of
Elijah and a Syrian general that was
converted through the influence of
Elijah
of course they heard about the true God
but I think there's some people that
maybe are gonna believe the message
preached to them through angels Hebrews
says some have entertained angels
unaware so there may be some exceptions
I think I think preachers need to be
careful about saying automatically that
everybody who did not hear from a
missionary is automatically lost
I think that's reckless thank you good
question next one that we have is Cindy
from Florida Cindy welcome to Bible
answers life hi pastor ah hi pastor dad
thank you for taking my call hi Cindy
thank you for calling I was wondering if
God has forgiveness for us why did he
not ever forgive Satan of his sin well
we don't know see there's a limit to
God's forgiveness for us first of all
God is very merciful he's very patient
but obviously a lot of people are gonna
be lost because they did not embrace his
mercy we don't know how long it was that
Satan was you're stirring things up in
heaven before he was finally evicted and
I think God maybe had mercy on him well
there is a condition - there's a
condition of forgiveness and it's true
no matter who the person is but we need
to repent we need to acknowledge our son
we need to come with a humble heart and
you know the devil as far as we know
never came with repentance never growl
HD sin is hardened his heart was like
Pharaoh back in the days of the Exodus
where every time the play stopped he
would just rebellion and that's kind of
with Satan's that he has gone past the
point of no return
yeah and ultimately the Pharaoh got
baptized
it was nothing yeah what kind of baptism
exactly so yeah I I think God may have
shown a lot of patience with Luther and
given him opportunity to humble himself
and repent and I think other angels
tried to reason with him and he hardened
his heart and there's nothing more God
can do he ultimately grieved away the
Holy Spirit and did what is referred to
as committing the unpardonable sin but
yeah I have actually got a book on the
unpardonable sin I think I think I asked
that question can the devil be forgiven
I think it's called beyond mercy beyond
mercy is the book it what and then it
says the subtitle what is the
unpardonable sin the number to call is
883 five six seven four seven you can
answer the book called beyond mercy it's
on the unpardonable sin we'll be able to
send it to anybody who calls and asks
annexed Foley's let's see Ruth listening
in Massachusetts Ruth welcome to the
program kind of question regret
regarding a proverbs 17:9 okay can you
clarify for me embed the word
transgression alright proverbs 17 verse
nine going there right now and it says
he who covers a transgression seeks love
but he who repeats the matter separates
friends well you know Jesus said forgive
us our trespasses as we forgive those
who trespass against us Salomon here in
proverbs are saying you know if if
you're aware of a friend who's made a
mistake don't advertise it or if maybe
they've been talking about somebody else
don't repeat it because you will
separate friends just be quiet about it
we don't need to repeat every
ill-advised thing someone has said
because it causes separation and so I
think he's talking about being gracious
not gossiping and causing separation of
friends if someone says something unkind
or uncharitable don't repeat it to
somebody else thank you all right good
question I haven't had that one for a
while and I think people need to hear
that
next colon that we have is Dan listening
from New Jersey Dan welcome to the
program
thank you I'm glad to be on your program
my question is when when the rapture
comes will people who practice to Sunday
Sabbath will they not have any chance of
being raptured well first of all when
the rapture happens you're talking about
the second coming of the Lord the next
coming yeah in the last days before
Jesus returns I think there's going to
be a big shaking in the world there's
going to be time of trouble and there's
also at the same time going to be a
great revival so that everybody in the
world is gonna be in one group or
another and so I think that everybody's
gonna either be following the faith that
was once delivered to the Saints or
they're gonna be following the Beast
you're only gonna have two groups I
think when when Jesus comes back you
know they're telling us in the studio
we've got one minute left I don't know
if we could squeeze in probably wouldn't
be fair to do that another question that
was a question you know just to follow
up on that question a little bit there -
it's you know the Bible speaks of God's
people at the end of time keeping his
commandments and I think throughout
history God has had faithful men and
women who have lived up to all the light
that they have and God judges us based
upon what we know but there is a great
revelation of light right before Jesus
comes Revelation chapter 18 talks about
this angel fly in the midst of heaven
crying with a loud voice babbling he's
fallen is fallen we're talking about
symbols here but a special message of
revival goes out just before the end and
it's gonna be exciting time where true
followers are gonna make this stand on
Bible truth hey thank you very much
listening friends you there's more every
day at amazing fact o RG God willing
we'll talk again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control
well you're hit with something new your
marriage your job your health you could
live to the stars but they don't have
the answers but this does the prophecy
Study Bible by amazing facts
it's 27 personal study guides lead you
on a life-changing journey get yours
today by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore com can't get enough amazing
facts Bible study you don't have to wait
until next week to enjoy more truth
filled programming visit the amazing
facts media library at aft vor G at aft
vor G you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aft vor
G if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our web site at WWF AG
0 RG and sign up for our free Bible
study course and make sure to check out
our online bookstore at AF bookstore
comm which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you know that
noah was present to the birth of Abraham
okay maybe he wasn't in the room but he
was alive and probably telling stories
about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of Revelation Bible
history calm is a free resource where
you can explore major Bible events and
characters enhance your knowledge of the
Bible and draw closer to God's Word
go deeper visit Bible History com
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm